have a look at the question and it says
the base of a pyramid is the
parallelogram abcd and you can see i've
drawn that up because i knew it was
going to be important
for all of my working here they provide
you the coordinates of the different
vertices
uh including uh the apex of the pyramid
which is point p
um though i will point out i mean if you
had a look through the question right
if you read through part one part two
part three maybe you will realize that
actually
you never ever need to refer to the apex
at least in the question
as stated because they don't ask you
anything about volume they never you ask
you to find out one of like the
upward sort of facing triangles or
anything like that so i'm actually going
to erase that bit of a distractor there
because it is irrelevant to the actual
questions that we are going to solve
whoops don't
erase the bits that we need so once we
know
a b c and d and we're actually going to
be playing around on this plane
you realize even though this is a 3d
question and we are going to pull out
some of our
you know 3d manipulation um in our
vectors actually you can more or less
regard this as a 2d
um question so that's why i've drawn my
parallelogram in two dimensions and i'm
quite happy with it
so the first thing we need to do is find
the values of a b and c
where is what are the coordinates of
this point capital
c now there's a bunch of different ways
to go about this
but the way i went about it was to
recognize one of the properties of a
parallelogram that we can take advantage
of in terms of vectors
if you is if you have a look at any two
opposite sides right so
uh you could have chosen um either pair
really i went with bc
and ad if you have a look at these two
sides we know
two things about those sides which are
namely that
like the it says on the tin they're
parallel to parallelogram after all
and also they are equal in magnitude so
being that they have the same direction
they have the same length this tells us
that these are actually going to be
they're going to have the same
displacement vector right so i can take
advantage of that fact
if i can work out say this displacement
vector a d
because i know the coordinates of h and
i can
equate that with the displacement vector
for b c which has some unknowns in it
that will help me work it out okay now
how do i do this just to remind you
because i know it's maybe you're a bit
rusty
for working out things like this how do
you work out the displacement vector
between
two points well think about this way
some of you may have the next line
already in your head because you've got
that memorized
but i always think okay to get from a to
d that's the same as going from a
to somewhere else like the origin and
then going via the origin to your final
destination which in this case is d
so ao plus od that concatenation or that
stringing of
vectors one after another by definition
gives you
a d um vector ao of course
is going from a to o is the same as
going backwards from o to a and the
reason why that's useful is because
that vector o a is right there right
it's 2 negative 1
3. so it's just kind of stated by
definition all i need to do is turn that
backwards and i'm quite happy if you
went straight to the line i mean some
people
will write it like this o d take away o
a because those are obviously equivalent
but
especially if you're like i can't
remember do i switch these around
much like trying to remember a formula i
always like to go back to something that
is absolutely rock solid
in my brain and then reasoning from
there most mathematicians
uh memorize very few results because
turner's facing their brain for that
kind of thing
all right now that you know what that is
it's just a matter of crunching the
numbers to find out what a d
is so negative o a is going to be
negative 2 1 negative 3 and we're adding
that to od
which we can just read off from the
question and that gives you from getting
this
right two and then four and then
negative four so far so good we can
employ a similar kind of logic to work
out b
c uh and hopefully you're following
along at this point
or maybe you did uh you know maybe you
did a b
a b and c d or d c that would also be
fine
um just remember by the way if you're
doing a b
make sure you're doing d c and not c d
because those are not the same vector
right and what i got for bc just a bit
of a spoiler
is that i got uh negative 4 plus
a and then i've got 2 plus b
and then negative 1 plus c
now what you can say is oh these two
vectors this one here
and this one here they are the same
displacement vector so all i need to do
is compare x's compare y's compare z's
and that's going to give me in this
instance what have i got here so
a take away 4 that's my x coordinate
or my x value for this vector rather
that's going to be equal to
2 so that gives me a value of 6 for a
doing the same for b b plus 2 is going
to be 4
so subtracting 2 from both sides give me
that
and then c minus 1 is going to be
negative 4 so when i add 1 to both sides
i get negative
3. okay that's it i found my values for
a
b and c that was part one
okay part two it says find the cosine of
the angle between the vectors a b
and a d so you can see we're talking
about
this one here a b and there's a d over
there
um how you going to do this can you go
ahead and post in the chat what's the um
what's the piece of knowledge from
vectors that we
it's you know frankly even though we're
in 3d at the moment it's a it's a 2d
vectors idea
uh well done viren has been enormously
succinct
very mathematician-like of you well done
so i can use the dot product
the dot product is going to be equal to
two different things right number one
we can just multiply x y and z
components between
up to day z a b and a d that'll give us
the dot product one way
and then we also have our other
definition which is the magnitude of one
times the magnitude of the other
multiplied by exactly what we're trying
to find
the cosine of the angle between them
right
so i'm just going to uh write that here
part 2.
i'm taking advantage of this right
magnitude of 1
magnitude of the other cosine of the
angle in between and that's going to be
equal to we would compare
each of the different components to each
other and multiply
through like so you can see all i need
to do to get cos theta i don't even need
to work out theta just because there
will do
is divide through by this so if you go
ahead and do that i'll just do one line
of working and then i'll get to the
answer because most of you said you were
okay with that
you can get some pythagoras on the left
hand side so i think you got
this is going to be this length here
4 plus 1 plus 4. i think that's what you
get from
a b if you have a look at that when you
do the subtraction and then when you get
a d i'm believing you're getting 4 plus
16 plus 16. it's almost
like when you think about what they add
up to like this question was designed
for that
and then when you're comparing uh your x
and your y and your z components this is
what i got um
here are my x's here are my y's
and then here are my z's
like so okay so cos theta
is going to be after you you know you
can have a look at that
that's going to be 9 so it's square root
of 3. this is going to be
36 so it's square root of 6. so
everything ends up nice and in whole
numbers so i believe you get 4 over
9. okay all right so then i'm up to part
three
i want to find the area of this
parallelogram now coming back to this
shape right
there's at least a couple of different
ways to work out this area
actually there's a whole lot of
different ways but in terms of working
out like what's the
what area formulas do i know because i
don't give this one right
um you could say half base times height
it's actually the same formula if you
want to think about this as like a
a leaning over rectangle if you had a
rectangle
which had this base and and this
perpendicular height
i'm just going to put some constructions
around here right there's the rectangle
you can see if you like slanted it over
this is now we're thinking back like
year 7 year 8 geometry right
this section here which is missing is
exactly equal to this section
here which is um which is added when you
lean over right
so we can work out a base and we can
work out a perpendicular height if we
want
but that seems extraneous that seems
like it's not using
part one or part two and the kinds of
information that we developed there
so instead i want to think about how can
i use the information that i already
know what's the
laziest possible way i can go about this
and i wonder if you're seeing right
in terms of the information i've already
got i've got this angle
in here right i also know to find out
you know the earlier parts there the
cosine of that angle i had to find out
these two lengths right that was
involved in the dot product
i know that i believe um a b is gonna be
that's gonna be three i think uh put it
in like so
that's three um and think a d is gonna
be
six right so i've got uh a side
another side and this angle that is
between them
we would call that an included angle
between
if i created whoopsie daisy i wanted to
create a straight line there hold on
there we go
that's going to give me the included
angle of the other two sides in a
triangle here right triangle a
b d so what i can do is using just that
information alone
that'll give me this triangle here let's
see if that'll snap together there we go
that will give me the area of that
triangle if i just use half a b
sine c and because of the properties of
a parallelogram you can even see because
my diagram is so awesome
that you're going to get a congruent
triangle on the other side so just
double this area
and off you go so i'm going to start
putting some working down for that
the area of abcd
is going to be the same as double the
area
of that triangle that i just highlighted
in green above which is triangle
a b d so that is double
of half a b sine c let's just have a
look
again here what is a b sine c uh
here's my a here's my b and here's my
sine
c so the way that i would actually write
that is i would say
it's that vector a b is the first
side uh the other vector a d is what i
had there and then the included angle
is going to be sine of now just be
careful
i had cos theta equals 4 over 9.
you could retrieve calculator here it
will handle a lot of the exact values
for you
um but when you hit equals at the very
end you'll get some decimal stuff and
you'll think
what is this if it's not rational your
calculator will have a bit of trouble
working out what that is even though it
might give you
um all the decimal places that you could
want we want as you can see
in part three the area of the base of
the pyramid without any approximation
they haven't said two decimal places or
whatever
right and we can't we can work this out
exactly so
i'm going to put in here cos inverse of
4
over 9. i'm now going to see
what i can do with the rest of this
before working that out these two are
going to cancel so that's nice
i already know what the two magnitudes
are so
these two here are going to give me
let's see lazy let's write that in
orange three
times six uh and then it's just a matter
of uh what is
what is this going to be over on this
side right what's this going to be
um this is calling back to some
knowledge you haven't used for a while
in right angle triangles
if you create a triangle here which has
an angle in it that gives you
cos inverse or a cosine of 4 over 9
that's
adjacent on hypotenuse right and in this
right angle triangle you can work out
what this
unknown is just by pythagoras so you can
see this is going to be the square root
of
9 squared which is 81 take away 4
squared which is 16
so that's the square root of 65.
i need that because i'm about to compute
you can see it over here
i'm about to compute sine right so
that's going to be opposite
on hypotenuse so i'm ready to pop that
in
that's square root of 65 over
9. looks like i'm going to get some
cancelling right so
there's a 3 in here and a 3 in here so
both of those will cancel with that 9
that 6 will leave a factor of 2 behind
so it seems to me like i'm getting 2
square root
of 65 and this is an area after all
so let's slap some units on there okay
so well done if you got there um i'm not
sure if you could find a more succinct
and more efficient way
um to get it or even if you had another
solution even if it's not more elegant
sometimes it's still nice to have
a different path through